we are going to continue to remain
vigilant
to address this just horrific tragedy
that we're facing
the enemy modified the numbers of those
who
lost lives we have 17 laws
nine our adults and eight are children
this is a really an evolving crisis
and so as it evolves and as we get new
information we're going to share it with
you
as well so you can let the public know
what we're going through we said this
yesterday and we will continue to say
this is an unspeakable tragedy
early this morning
i was joined with the chancellor
we visited
every school
in the area where the children our young
scholars lost their lives
we sat down with the principal and the
teachers
and just wanted to have a private moment
to let them know that we are here to
support them as they go through this
tragedy they shared just personal notes
of these children and it was something
that we heard universally
about each child that we lost
is how much they smiled how much they
brought life to the school
and
not only did this fire
leave
a
burning pain
in the hearts of people in this
community
but it has
left a burning pain in the children and
the teachers and the faculties of this
school
we will support these schools in every
way
possible in the coming months
educators students staff
all of them
realize that they're going through a
traumatic moment and we want to be here
for them
and it is clear that these families
and
the entire community is receiving
support from across the country
just a few moments ago
i received a call from president biden
and he has made it clear
that whatever we need
the white house is going to be there for
us
he has
just sent a very strong message that
this is on the radar
of the entire globe uh what's what has
happened here
the council general of the dominican
republic is here with us
and his team uh this is a a global
tragedy because
of the bronx in new york city is
representative of the ethnicities and
cultures across the globe
and so everyone is feeling the pain of
what we are experienced but i would tell
you this and i say over and over again
we're going to get through this moment
we're going to get through this moment
and we're going to get through it
together
and this tragedy is not going to define
us
it is going to show our resiliency as we
help the families through this
in the middle of such pain
we have witnessed such a high level of
heroism
from the hospital staff the doctors the
nurses the administrators who are
already going through
crises
with the pandemic
but we also witness a high level of
heroism
through those first responders the ems
the firefighters i would say this over
and over again
watching them go in the building
even without
having a full
air tank still pushing through the dark
smoke and rescuing families in this
building
our firefighters as first responders
really showed why uh it is imperative to
give them the support support that they
need and i want to thank commissioner
nygro for just really
leading this charge yesterday being out
here throughout the day leading his men
and women to do what was needed to save
as many families as possible and to
every grieving family 8.8 million new
yorkers see you as their family members
and we are here together to push through
this
and so some clear messages we want to
send one
for those who want to help
please do not drop donations off the
fire stations or ems stations
let them do their jobs there are real
outlets our elected officials are here
you can drop them off at the offices or
other facilities that we will put in
place if you want to do so if you want
to help financially
we have the mayor's fund to advance new
york every dollar raised will go
directly
to the family members that are involved
so this way we can help families in a
real way
and if we take one message from this
that commissioner nigro has mentioned
several times close the door
close the door that was embedded in my
head as a child watching the commercials
over and over again we're going to
double down on that message my
conversation with the chancellor of this
morning
we're going to send out communications
to all of our schools and state that we
want our children to receive the same
level of reinforcement muscle memory is
everything and if we can drill that in
we can save lives by closing the doors
not only in the city but across the
entire globe this painful moment can
turn into a purposeful moment as we send
the right message of something simple as
closing the door
and we
i want to really thank
all the communities leaders that are
here in this community
a large a member of the african diaspora
uh and recognizing
some of the communication gaps
building those bridges having the
community come together as a whole
to
make sure that we provide the services
that are needed
for this community to get
get on the road of healing from this
devastating event no one wants to hear
about the loss of life and that is even
more impactful when that loss consists
of a children's of this level in this
magnitude
before turning it over to
the other representatives are here i
want to turn it over to the chancellor
who visited the schools with me today
and thank him for showing the
infrastructure support to the educators
in the school they were appreciative of
your presence and showed how serious
this matter is to all of us chancellor
banks
thank you mr mayor
it was certainly
my pleasure
to join the mayor
this morning
as we visited four schools
two traditional public schools
and two charter schools
and i think it's important to note that
um
that when it comes to moments like this
there's no separation between us these
are all of our children
and to hear
the heartbreak
from the principles of each one of those
schools
the teachers
the school safety officers
the custodial workers
we came there to thank them
to let them know that we are here for
them
but they each one of them also told us
about each one of the young people who
who died
they're not just a name
they told us stories about each one of
them
and my heart broke
as we heard
just about how passionate
each young person was and how they came
to life for us
one teacher read a letter
that he had just gotten a few days ago
and it was just it was just
heartbreaking
and so
i want to say also we sent out a
i sent out a letter to
every school
uh principal
um and educator across the city this
morning
asking that we all take time to reflect
on this tragedy
but also to make sure that we are
providing opportunities to talk about
fire safety
during this winter season
there are a lot of people in their homes
and their apartments were using these
these heaters
and unfortunately we have these kinds of
act accidents and certainly nothing as
tragic as this but this is the time to
make this
an educational moment
and as the mayor said
something as simple as closing the door
and our young people need to be taught
that they need to be reminded of that
and take that as something that they
will take with them for the rest of
their lives as well and so
um i just simply want to thank all of
the personnel
at all of our schools
that have been infected
the teachers the principals the
administrators the librarians the
custodians the school safety workers the
nurses
everyone has been impacted
by this is a monumental tragedy
and uh we just send prayers
and all of our deepest thoughts with the
families who are going through so much
god bless